et un truc je suis un marché parallèle
pour se procurer des oeuvres est ce que
tu es au courant
ça commence par le et ça termine
parcours ah ouais c'est quoi on s'est
rendu compte quand on dit ce qui était
déjà en vente sur le site de petites
annonces
je te propose d'essayer de négocier ton
propre disque à ces normes
tu me laisses commencé mais c'est chaque
présente mal je te demanderai ton est
alors ans avec la première annonce
s'agit d'un certain romain qui vante ont
cédé 10 euros on va essayer d'avoir à 8
euros même proposé un échange avec un
truc le slip de montier de moncton ap on
se gare parti c'est sa personne en se
gardant roma rotonde l'appellerons c'est
l' écoute coup de fil demande si ce
n'est fait ok oui bonsoir à l'eau oui
bonjour à l'eau alors oui bonne voie je
vous entends ado oui je savais qu'on
arrive à patates on est à l' on à
l'époque là on héros en 2020 si on a en
1977 enrichir les gars c'est à duda
cadran
on rappelle l'année qui auront bien
bourlingué à l'eau oui mais soit bonsoir
robin des toits ou petermann qui est un
vrai alors romain c'est cyril hanouna on
est en direct sur ces huit touche pas à
mon poste hanouna n'ont pas du tout la
blague c'est montiel la scène où la roma
roma je t'appelle parce que j'ai vu que
tu avais mis le cd de vianney en vente
oui oui à 10 euros pourquoi 10 euros
pour eux tu veux le vendre
je ne sais pas quand mais je viens de
castelnaudary d'accord mais et j'avais
du mobile du monde à paris et le cuivre
à ma copine m'a quitté et je voulais
ouvrir
j'ai dit jovial et aux non non vous vous
allez l'écouter l'eau il est il est bien
céder dia n'est quand même pas je suis
un peu désolé je voulais acheter cinq
ans de monsieur à seclin non parce
qu'une rupture sentimentale gens c'est
peut-être l'un d'eux allô oui oui oui il
en train de brouiller la cage où son
usine géante et je serais intéressé par
ces nissan la montée le talent est là
bas ça ici une assiette ce qui peut
acheter
donc je vous ai très bien votre cd de
gagner parce qu'en fait on les romains
sécher en fait je suis vianney donc si
tu veux moi si je sais pas il est vrai
que c'est que tu vends mon album je
comprends un peu mieux j'ai les boules
pour toi mon pote et si je peux faire un
tête pour tu récupères ta copine si ça
peut aider
je suis là mon gamin tu penses que tu
peux récupérer tama fout pas à la part
de l égard de l'album pour la prochaine
robin cet album tu peux pas dire ça
romain elle je le comprends le poste à
l'eau pour tt tt ou d'à toi là je suis
tu peux tu es loin des loin du plateau
là bien avant ce bateau là ils n'en sont
pas tout c'est de venir tout de suite
way romain mallet là
[Musique]
c'est son doudou c'est son frère mais
nous et qu'on ait jamais vu
jarrett accent du sud mais ça va et ça
se ressent
on n'a pas le même style mais on a la
même passion non mais alors c'est ton
petit-frère autant que lui c'est mon
grand frère
c'est vrai que toi tu as quel un mois
suite à l'esprit des aînés dans un
délire et sur les braises sartec la
moustache frère j'adore la station où
elle a ça ça ça va être repris par tout
le frère de vienne alors il faut écrit
des livres
oui le lie à s'abstenir oui ouais ben
alors ça c'est chantier parce que moi
qui suis un amoureux de la lecture ça
fait plaisir qu'elle est aussi la seule
émission simple faut rester sérieux
c'est ça parle de quoi dit moi comme ça
tu vas tu l'as lu belge est un lion qui
avait appauvri et bail à léon comme un
oeuf s'entraîner c'est un site les
jeunes csu jeune planteur idéaliste qui
lance une révolte par humanisme l'oignon
sa crinière et edwards était un amour en
tout cas d'être venu ouais merci mais il
est beau bassin j'aimerais bien il est
beau gosse est célibataire
non voilà alors une famille
un super alors bonne idée il aime bien
brano et la chanson française
cela va profiter avec des fier de ton
frère ou pas je suis super fier ouais
depuis le début il fait ça super bien es
tu veux pas prendre un peu la guitare va
nous faire un petit truc devant ton
frère là c'est grave
moi je suis avec danton fréron ça c'est
une belle séquence une belle surprise
merci célébration est faible 1 qu'est ce
que vous me voulez de la poisse cet
album allez mon violon vadim ségou un
petit bout parce qu'on est quand même
chez tpf pas faire plus de 15 secondes
d'affilée j'ai déchiré tous les dit
oh
non je ne vendrai jamais la place du
premier qui l'a dit je de même sur ton
visage voit son visage c'est ainsi que
tu es paix vous à moi c'est moi j'avoue
qu'ils me suis invité dans sa villa dans
la vie où elle n'a rien demandé si
l'averse du tout chez toi et moi
on à travers sa 2 à 3
et si l'averse plus touché trois mois
prends ma main de beau papa
doudou
j attendais pas
je te laisserai pas
même sans même sens hanouna